für mein empfinden mit große gewaltig
können das heißt es denn deutschland
gemeinsam machen es aber keinen satz
dieses gewusel macht mich
glücklich sein wirklich ein gutes wort
muss ich sagen es in sich total
schlüssig
schüler auf dem über das wahrscheinlich
einer der besten anfänge
bisher das ist schlau wenn man weiß wie
es geht also der spot der csu
ändert sich ziemlich gut gemacht
eigentlich hatte glaube ich gar kein
geld gekostet zeit auch wir leben in
einem unglaublichen gewinn von
stimmungen lobbygruppen und zum teil
extremen positionen die einen fordern
die völlige abkehr von jeden regeln und
die anderen wollen die menschen ein
zwangskorsett stecken den ganzen tag
will ihren
das kann man wohl dosiert
markus söder hat eigentlich in seiner
gesamten politischen karriere schon so
viel bildschirmzeit bekommen dass man
erst mal wirklich was
man wirklich das muss man wohl dosieren
auch so unserem wahlwerbespot auch
irgendwie braucht es jemanden der das
ganze zusammen führt mit wahrem sehr gut
vorbildlich ohne fahrradhelm ist dumm
das zusammenhält
der stabilität gewährleistet aber der
braucht dass sich etwas am ort
stabilität gewährleisten
darauf dringen dass ich was erneuert ok
also sind wir wieder bei klimawandel
bekämpfen wohlstand erhalten gibt es
kein manns portemonnaie alle sind
glücklich planet freut sich ja also die
aufgabe die welt zu erhalten bevor sie
untergeht es ist ein sehr gute idee
finde ich dachte jetzt nicht dass sie
exklusiv der csu gehört dass ich meine
aufgabe zu und fragte
ich möchte ehrlicherweise nicht vor
unseren kindern für sein
ich möchte nicht dass wir uns den
kindern eine welt schlechter begeben als
wir es übernommen in dem moment wo die
kamera unten es und zeigt so oder so im
gegenlicht überlegens kurs funktioniert
die inszenierung leider nicht so einfach
weil dann soll das gesicht er so
bisschen feierlich war er ist und nicht
so
schwer ist der kamerablick eigentlich
sogar ihren soll ich habe meinen kindern
versprochen dass wenig verantwortung
habe ich alles nach bestem wissen und
gewissen tun dafür dass wir wenn wir
probleme erkennen die auch lösen eines
der wichtigsten ist diese welt zu
erhalten sie ein stück weit auch zu
retten
es ist unsere aufgabe ist ein großer
anspruch aber dem müssen wir uns stellen
wir sind eine minute im video nur markus
söder ja das haben sich bisher also
daran die anderen natürlich waren sich
zurückhaltend eine minute volles
programm markus söder und erzielt
einfach nur stark und dann geht er durch
seine schöne bayerische landschaft er
weiß jemand wovon er redet ganz
offensichtlich und wenn er sich um kopf
hat ja eigentlich das was er will schon
erreicht nämlich eine grüne gesunde
widerspruchsfreie
welt mit fahrradwegen toll dass er
fahrradfahren kann finde ich eigentlich
auch toll ab und jetzt finde ich nicht
so cool aber gut
aber fahrradwege gibt es eben reichlich
in bayern ganz offensichtlich und es
gibt sonst nichts in bayern keine fabrik
das ist alles bereits völlig digital
wahrscheinlich gibt es auch digitale
dichter und denker bereits in bayern
wer vertritt in wirklich bayern am ende
in berlin am besten wem interessiert es
ob bayern in berlin am besten vertreten
wird wenn jemand was fuer bayern.de wenn
er möchte das bayerische interessen in
berlin wirklich vertreten sind das ist
ein polizist bayerns lobbygruppe in
berlin
sogar wir haben schon das copyright für
die interessen bayerns auf bundesebene
und die tun das nicht übertrieben aber
doch schon sehr nachhaltig umsetzen
kommen jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
markus söder ist so launig bayerischer
ministerpräsident also es geht doch um
die bundestagswahl will söder in diesem
spot dann doch kanzler werden weil er
spricht ja nur von sich er spricht denn
nur was er alles tun will und kann
alles wäre wäre auf dem besten wege wenn
der sünder kanzlerkandidat geworden wäre
aber ganz offensichtlich so wie er
gefilmt ist gibt es da noch was drüber
über dem kanzler und gaswerk er wenn man
ihm erhält das sind wir auch antreiber
und motor
[Musik]
ich glaube ich lass das jetzt mal so
stehen